so renato was beautiful enough
to go out
good night there is a thread that gave the [ __ ] for the
other was the strong one who likes ugly
[Music] has
always been guided by the dismissal only
make person says demanded even there is no
goal auto sport and what
but  ready let's see what it will be
[Music] it
was my first work in the people square
that being it offered here in my
homeland I had a special taste
for commanding easter sales poor
children we be careful to have
toys it is bought in a store  and
since I was a child I liked to work with
clay and make small figures
with clay we don't know how to do it
we will have there I was our grandmothers she
made things to play
one came out I speak is a white male it was
when fear plays in the ports
I was a companion in the  flamengo as I
like football and a
natural Madeiran that comes some company cast
stay more in u
I'm going to work at the airport it was magical the
cases I didn't hear that the airport and
passing through  name of ronaldo
nowadays everyone can sculpt
modeling clay objective was to pay
homage to cristiano ronaldo who also
thought that this launch pad not
an answer career sculptor
were located in the world without the part
any dog fly like this in the new ones and play
the clay is to transmit someone who will
emanate may have a
similar story given the assistance the one
who boasts ronaldo get out of retirement just
like emanuel managed to turn around the
sale today is the best in the world in
what is the most boring to do
when i got there built it
already  have done what i know is duck and that
anything ronaldo through the
messages by we send throne his new
after a report friar who could be a
bit in his environment
these young women here who could wear
out another plan as well as about the newspaper
taken likes  all 211
but ready to norcon thanks from rye
feeling of seeing understands my part
was in the victory is what i mean
just get to put  sign of ronaldo i
was already with the v
go my son with the mother i bought
a ball for the
goal we would arrive at our house remember
come back aboard the cruise ronaldo
autographed by cristiano ronaldo
[Music]
there was no conversation
unfortunately
until then it was  be a despot glory
because with your career
like that when you get a text ready
[Music]
unifor to the media system while
piris wellington in you in dom louis 1
for flamengo
the plan is obliged for smoking but look it's
already done all open ball is rolling
artifices nos future of the public sector
nabil el hatico in capim if it was known if there was
a thread of light highlights in god 5
on
average ip had already had to talk about ronaldo
the same idea that no one had the
courage to take the initiative that
I have the mermaid that I have and to
propose to present her work on
social networks was for those people to
plant the courage to say face to face
with what they think about leaving everyone
wrong and 96 is  ado of so much criticism
I think it wasn't jesus he didn't
always dream of making it but I already know but it's
important to say that the area has a
form of expression it's not an exact science it's
been 12 years he comes to life he has
machines they have our thesis squid  he must
also from israel from the next
star regional saturday his country he only had beer
with paper
flowers that died in the groups still the
family where i know from time to 16 jonas the
jeans working abreu to
[Music]
the
stutter aec and ass
[Music]
the rural
ae
[Music]
is
the angels too
[Music]
junior is a witch
candinho no
[Music]
so what am
ae
[Music]
after strong it
will be late
only you manuel tries to show who is after all
emanuel santos
[Music]
[Applause]
in vila verde vers round change how the
food is easy it wasn't low
light signal without putting an ambulance in
learning to play with the written concert
that the and ready
here I am I think
[Music]  ]
the british is mounted
[Music]
this one of ronaldo who made it, if it doesn't have to
be the way he did it, it already has - that it's
been here from oblivion for a long
time now it's also sometimes has a certain
josé ea of going against the usual to make an im
act because although there are only the  that they
do if they just command it never had but
there are already many people who don't go
there what I've learned during
all this time is that although there is a number of
people who can see a positive of the
work, this is a small and succinct number of
strength
[Music]
it's weak and cold